You have a number of,
of,
of success stories in,
in Africa in the last 15 to 20 years.
A country like Ghana has a huge
substantial growth rates.
Uh,
there's some countries in,
in,
in cells in Africa who are also doing
quite well in Asia.
I was in Bangladesh for a couple of
weeks ago and that's the country facing
enormous challenges.
Uh,
but there's 150 million people living in
a country,
something twice the size of Ireland.
I don't know what the appropriate level
of state and the United States is,
but it's,
it's,
it's a small piece of land and,
uh,
you know,
they've been growing against all the
odds and surviving.
There's still huge poverty,
but they're still making some progress.
And obviously,
as are some other cases in,
particularly in Asia,
places like Cambodia who have came out
of a dreadful,
a internal conflict 30,
30 odd years ago and have made a lot of
progress.
So I think the foundation stones have to
be good governance.
I think countries have to invest in
education,
uh,
obviously,
set and get,
find some way of partnership between
governments and civil society and
governments I think have to be willing
to give the space to civil society to
enable them to make the cost
contribution and enable at over time
institutional development for that
governmental and nongovernmental level
to develop an,
and,
and that is ultimately,
I think what needs to be done in,
in,
uh,
in a country.
And obviously good,
well grounded policy policy is
important.
I mean,
policy that we'll,
uh,
we'll put attend if in a country,
for example,
uh,
that has a big proportion of its economy
dealing in agriculture.
There has to be a,
you know,
uh,
do focus on that.
And I think the food crisis earlier this
year brought it home to people that for
the last 20 to 30 years,
agriculture and rural development as a
sector has largely been neglected.
And there is a daunting at,
at,
on leaders both at national and
international level,
that that has to change.